This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难的抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的心理治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦于黑男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人带着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，听听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难的抉择》。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，这就是选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些困难，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。也就是英文里的TWO percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取自己的行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is great to have you here back for another episode. Today I also want to formally welcome you to this week's little mini series where I'm going to be focusing on how to create your dream life in your 20s. So my kind of idea behind this
相信你的闺蜜。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客里，我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目。今天我还想正式欢迎大家来到本周的小系列节目，我将重点探讨如何在二十岁时打造你的理想生活。所以我的这个想法
segment, why I thought that it was important to talk about today, perhaps something that I hadn't spoken about before, is that there is so much evidence, advice, psychology, even my personal observations that don't always make it into one episode altogether. I feel like I have a lot of different episodes for unique conundrums and unique experiences, but what I really wanted to do was combine that all into two episodes where we look at all. the different dimensions of our 20s that I think we experience the greatest sense of worry and confusion, things like our careers, our finances, love, friendships, the future, and our personal growth, and really provide a bit of a blueprint or a guide for what is the best practice, what is the
环节，为什么我认为今天讨论这个很重要，也许是我以前没有谈过的事情，那就是有太多的证据、建议、心理学，甚至我个人的观察，并不总是能完整地塞进单期节目中。我觉得我有很多针对独特困境和独特经历的不同单集，但我真正想做的是把这些结合成两期节目，我们来看看20年代的所有不同维度，我认为我们在这些维度上经历着最强烈的担忧和困惑，比如我们的职业、财务、爱情、友情、未来和个人成长，并真正为最佳实践、什么是
best thing to do during this decade around these different ideas and experiences that is not only going to allow us to really enjoy the freedom of this time, but also set us up for the future. I think this decade is so incredibly romanticized and the stakes feel so high to kind of get everything right and to set ourselves up for success whilst also not really missing out on some of those crucial, fun, carefree times. And I think we all deserved a bit of a holistic bird's eye view of exactly what kind of balance to strike and also some reassurance that you are not behind, there is no need to rush, there is still time, and also what the future may have in store. How to approach that daunting, sometimes overwhelming confusion with
在这个十年里围绕这些不同想法和经历的最好做法，不仅能让我们真正享受这段时间的自由，还能为未来打下基础。我认为这个十年被极度浪漫化了，把一切都做好并为成功奠定基础的赌注感觉太高了，同时又不想错过那些关键的、有趣的、无忧无虑的时光。我认为我们都应得一个整体的鸟瞰视角，确切了解该如何把握平衡，同时也得到一些 reassurance，即你并没有落后，完全没有必要着急，时间还来得及，以及未来会有怎样的期待。如何带着
excitement rather than fear. So this is part one of the Creating Your Dream Life mini series where we are going to cover tips and theories around achieving fulfillment, direction, and growth in our careers and, you know, our financial lives. And part two, we're going to cover relationships, friendships, love, as well as our physical and our emotional and crucially our spiritual well-being. So this episode, I really want to get into and decode all of the kind of mysteries and confusions around making career and financial choices in your 20s that feel right and feel satisfying, but also allow us to really build this really wonderful future that we want without having the regret and the fear of the what-ifs. A question I get all the time in that, I think in fact I ask myself a lot
兴奋而不是恐惧去面对那种令人畏惧的、有时甚至是压倒性的困惑。所以这是“打造你的理想生活”迷你系列的第1部分，我们将探讨在职业生涯和财务生活中实现满足感、方向感和成长的技巧与理论。在第2部分中，我们将探讨人际关系、友情、爱情，以及我们的身体、情感，至关重要的是我们的精神健康。所以本期节目，我真的很想深入探讨并解码20年代在做出正确且令人满意的职业和财务选择时的所有神秘感和困惑，同时也让我们无需对那些“如果当初”抱有遗憾和恐惧，就能真正建立我们想要的这个非常美好的未来。我经常听到的一个问题，事实上我认为我自己也经常问自己
is, how do I know that the decisions I'm making right now and not the same decisions that I'm going to regret in five or 10 years. Because this is our first decade of adulthood, we often don't have the hindsight to comprehend just how much our lives can and will change in the next five to 10 years. And they may pan out in ways that we don't expect. So because we are all very new to this decade and new to this experience, we feel very boxed in by, I would say, a series of choices that have been socially imposed on us, particularly three or four options in particular. Do you work? Do you travel? Do you pursue further education? Or do you settle down? You know, I think that what comes from that is this series of what if questions, the series of kind of pick me or make a choice situation. So do I go to
就是，我怎么知道我现在做出的决定，不是我五到十年后会后悔的决定呢？因为这是我们步入成年的第一个十年，我们常常没有后见之明，去理解我们的生活在接下来的五到十年里会有多大以及将会有怎样的改变。而且它们的发展方式可能会出乎我们的意料。所以因为我们对这个十年和这段经历都非常陌生，我觉得我们被一系列强加给我们的社会选择严重框住了，特别是其中三四个选项。你要工作吗？你要去旅行吗？你要继续深造吗？还是你要安定下来？你知道，我认为随之而来的是一系列“如果”式的问题，一系列“选我”或“做抉择”的情境。所以我是去
uni and pursue professional success of being, you know, a lawyer, a doctor, an architect, or do I go traveling? Do I spend the next 10 years climbing the corporate ladder? Or do I pursue my passions and my pipe dreams? Sometimes it feels like every choice we make closes more doors than it opens. If I'm this type of person, the type that is eager for financial independence and professional success, then I have to say goodbye to this other potential version of myself, that really free-spirited traveler with endless time but also very little money. And I wish that I could be every possible version of myself. I wish that I didn't have to choose.
上大学并追求成为律师、医生、建筑师这样的职业成功，还是去旅行？我是花十年时间在企业阶梯上往上爬，还是追求我的激情和白日梦？有时感觉我们做的每一个选择，关上的门比打开的都要多。如果我是这种类型的人，那种渴望经济独立和职业成功的人，那么我就必须向另一个潜在的自己告别，那个拥有无尽时间但钱很少的真正自由奔放的旅行者。我希望自己能成为所有可能的版本。我希望自己不必做出选择。
It's something that I hear constantly. And I guess the question that comes from that is, why can't we kind of have it all? Why can't we be at all? I think a big misconception we face during this decade is that the choices we are making now will be our final answer. Part of that is this major contradiction inherent in our 20s that can make things so confusing but also wonderful. You know, in one year we are told that this is the decade of opportunity where we are kind
这是我经常听到的。我想由此产生的问题是，为什么我们不能鱼与熊掌兼得呢？为什么我们不能成为所有人呢？我认为在这个十年中我们面临的一个巨大误解，就是我们现在做出的选择将是我们的最终答案。部分原因在于我们二十岁时固有的这种重大矛盾，它会把事情弄得非常令人困惑但也无比美妙。你知道，一年里有人告诉我们，这是充满机遇的十年，我们被给予
of given a few years of free passes to really take our time and explore. And then in the other year is this little voice telling us that we are, falling behind, that we should have figured it out by now, that this is where our life foundation is established. I talk about this concept quite a bit on the show, but I think our 20s are a continuous example of what we call the paradox of choice. So the paradox of choice is this theory that suggests when we have an abundance of options, actually what that requires is more effort and when we have more options, we feel less satisfied with our choices compared to when we have fewer. And when we think about the landscape of our 20s, something that we are is very much
了几年的“免责期”，可以真正慢慢来去探索。然后到了另一年，又有另一种声音告诉我们，我们在掉队，我们现在应该已经把一切都搞明白了，这就是我们生活地基奠定的时候。我在节目中经常谈到这个概念，但我认为我们的二十岁就是我们所谓的“选择悖论”的不断上演。所以“选择悖论”这个理论表明，当我们有大量选择时，实际上这需要付出更多的努力；而当我们有更多选择时，与选择较少时相比，我们对自己的选择反而感到更不满意。当我们审视二十岁的环境时，我们所处的一种状态其实是
spoiled for choice. And we might think that that is more liberating. We might think that that gives us more freedom, but what a lot of these psychologists are saying is really that choice actually paralyzes us because we don't know how to weigh up all of the pros and cons, the costs and benefits of these decisions. So we are a generation facing the curse of too much choice. And maybe that is what's contributing to heightened levels of anxiety around not making the most of our formative years or worse yet. I think there's fear of making a choice and it being the wrong one. Something we really need to acknowledge before we start this episode is that this decade is not always going to be glamorous and romantic. I think we constantly think that we should be further along, that we should
乱花渐欲迷人眼（有太多的选择）。我们可能会认为这更具解放性。我们可能会认为这给了我们更多自由，但许多心理学家真正要说的是，选择实际上让我们陷入瘫痪，因为我们不知道如何权衡这些决定的所有利弊、成本和效益。所以我们这一代人面临着“选择过多的诅咒”。也许正是这一点导致了更高级别的焦虑，担心未能充分利用我们的塑造期，或者更糟糕的是。我认为有一种恐惧，那就是做出选择却选错了。在我们开始这期节目之前，我们需要真正承认的一点是，这个十年并不总是光鲜亮丽和充满浪漫的。我认为我们总是觉得我们应该走得更远，我们应该
have this career of our dreams or even an idea of what that dream should be by a certain age. But when you talk to more and more people about this, you kind of realize that everyone is just as confused as the next. And we learn a lot of what we think our lives should be like from very unrealistic, I would say, narrow hues, from very highly idealized depictions of what this decade should be, from movies, from cinema, and unfortunately, a lot of them are false. So there's two things that I've come to realize. Number one, we need to throw out any kind of thinking or prediction of what you think your life should look like. The vision you have for your future right now is going to change a million times and where you think you'll end up is probably not going to be
在某个年龄前拥有梦想中的职业，甚至对这个梦想应该是什么有个概念。但当你和越来越多的人谈论这个话题时，你就会意识到每个人其实都和别人一样迷茫。我们认为生活应该是什么样的，很多都来自于非常不切实际的、我可以说狭隘的视角，来自于对这个十年应该是什么样的高度理想化描绘，来自于电影、影视作品，而不幸的是，其中很多都是假的。所以我意识到两件事。第一，我们需要抛弃任何关于生活应该是什么样的想法或预测。你现在对未来的愿景会改变一百万次，你以为自己最终会去的地方，很可能不会是
where you actually end up. I would say the chances are highly unlikely. You know, I finished high school thinking I was going to work in politics. Then I graduated uni and I was a management consultant. And now, three years later, you know, I make a psychology podcast full time. that wasn't what I had in mind. That was a completely different idea to what I had even 12 months ago. But I think it's even better because I let life surprise me and I didn't tie myself down to a particular idea of who I needed to be. I let myself change. I let myself make mistakes because I think that's firmly what I think this decade is for. That is my underlying philosophy throughout this whole idea of creating your dream life. allow yourself to make mistakes, allow yourself to accept change. I think secondly, no decision or
你真正到达的地方。我想说，这种概率微乎其微。你知道，我高中毕业时以为自己会从事政治工作。然后我大学毕业，成了一名管理咨询顾问。现在，三年后，你知道的，我全职做了一个心理学播客。这并不是我原先计划的。这和我甚至在12个月前的想法都完全不同。但我认为这甚至更好，因为我让生活给我带来惊喜，我没有把自己束缚在“我需要成为什么样的人”这种特定概念上。我让自己去改变。我让自己犯错，因为我认为这正是这个十年存在的意义。这是贯穿“打造你的理想生活”这一整个理念的底层哲学。允许自己犯错，允许自己接受改变。我认为第二点，没有任何决定或
experience is ever a waste of your time and you also have the agency to change your reality at any point. It's really never too late to make a life-altering decision. You can be 50 and decide to go back to school. You can be 35 and quit your job. You can be 80 before you really, you know, find your passion. and you start your first book, you meet the love of your life. You're not a passive actor or a sidekick in your own life. That's something we really need to remember. You are the main character. So what's kind of stopping you from trying on different versions of yourself
经历会是在浪费你的时间，而且你随时都有能力改变你的现实。做出改变人生的决定永远都不嫌晚。你可以在50岁时决定重返校园。你可以在35岁时辞职。你甚至可以在80岁时才真正找到自己的激情
and seeing which one fits? You know, what's stopping you from deciding that one day, you know, the corporate life isn't for you, you're quitting your job, or maybe you're doing the reverse. You can give a million reasons why you cannot, do that, but I think when your happiness is the number one priority, especially during this decade where I think we're allowed to be a lot more selfish than other decades when you're kind of on this journey of creating your dream life. Happiness is really the core factor in your
去写第一本书，遇到你一生的挚爱。你不是自己生命中的被动演员或配角。这是我们需要牢记的一点。你是主角。那么是什么阻止你去尝试不同版本的自己
decision making. So in this episode, part one of this episode, we are going to break down my 10 key tips to getting the most out of your career, your finances and your time in your 20s to create your dream life, set yourself up for success, but also really enjoy this sacred period of your life. So without further ado, let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the
看看哪个最适合你呢？你知道是什么阻止你某天突然决定，企业生活不适合你，你要辞职，或者也许你在做相反的事情？你可以列出一百万个不能这样做的理由，但我认为当你的快乐成为第一优先级时，尤其是在这个十年里，我认为与其他十年相比，我们可以更自私一点，当你踏上打造理想生活这段旅程时。快乐确实是你
wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap
决策的核心因素。所以在本期节目中，也就是本期节目的第一部分，我们将细数我的10个核心建议，帮助你在20多岁时充分利用你的职业生涯、财务状况和时间，打造你的理想生活，为成功奠定基础，同时也真正享受你人生中这段神圣的时期。废话不多说，让我们开始吧。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，这就是选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开交流，看穿那些主宰
Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here.
健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾深信种子油生来就会引发炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些困难，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、健康的人。在I-Hart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。也就是英文里的TWO%。你还记得当戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so.
双击（轻拍）利尔·吉姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟利尔·吉姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回溯过去》（Look Back at it）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black. people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那一切的。其中包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔做客的节目，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的快克毒品。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为快克。我随时都可以聊一聊快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在台面上，所以。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难的抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人、你最喜欢的心理治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们用记分牌来看待生活，生活变成了一场场胜负。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是，这是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难的抉择》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
打开你的免费iHeartRadio应用。搜索《艰难的抉择》（Learn the Hardway）并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都被用在了哪里。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The big dilemma, I think that we need to overcome first and foremost when we're working towards this idea. idea of creating our dream life, is actually understanding what that looks like. Now, that's a highly individual question, depending on factors like our values, family expectations, culture, even the books and movies that we've been exposed to, that conceptualization is going
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、莱斯利，迈克尔·马林西尼。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
to look really different for everyone. You know, for some people, our 20s are about complete freedom and minimal responsibility. And for others, they're focused on settling down or pursuing love or your soulmate. In fact, I really think that on this whole planet, you could never find two people who are perfectly aligned on what they want from this decade, because there isn't one correct answer. I think where we get in trouble is when we compare our idea of happiness and success as well to someone else's. And we really begin to doubt whether our aspirations are actually good enough or whether someone else hasn't more figured out than us. That right there, I think, is a one-way ticket to very deep, emotional, spiritual, mental dissatisfaction
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没结束。在Iheart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。当我们朝着“打造你的理想生活”这个理念努力时，我认为首先需要克服的最大困境，其实是理解那到底是什么样子的。这是一个高度因人而异的问题，取决于我们的价值观、家庭期望、文化，甚至我们接触过的书籍和电影等因素，这种概念化
because someone else's ambition and motivation for pursuing a certain path is not going to be aligned with yours. And I think focusing on someone else's plan, focusing on someone else's idea of fulfillment, someone else's success, just really detracts from your own enjoyment of your life because you're constantly holding up a mirror to someone else's. as the saying goes, you know, energy flows where attention goes. And if there's one thing that you need to create your dream life during this decade, it is to direct all of your energy into what is going to make you happy, both in the moment and in the future.
对每个人来说都会大不相同。你知道，对某些人来说，二十多岁意味着完全的自由和最小的责任；而对其他人来说，他们专注于安定下来或追求爱情或灵魂伴侣。事实上，我真的认为在这整个星球上，你永远找不到两个在对这十年的诉求上完全契合的人，因为并没有一个标准答案。我认为我们陷入麻烦的时候，是我们把自己的快乐和成功标准与别人的进行了比较。并且我们开始怀疑我们的追求是否真的足够好，或者别人是否比我们把生活过得更明白。我认为，这恰恰是通往极度情感、精神和心理不满的单程车票
So our first exercise is to determine what kind of decade you want your 20s to be. Noting that this can, and I think definitely will change, and you should really be testing this idea regularly. But at every stage, when you find yourself perhaps at a crossroads or feeling really stuck, which we know is a super common experience, what you need to ask yourself is, A, what makes you happy, B, what makes you fulfilled? Because those are different things. And C, what conditions are necessary to fulfill those two factors.
因为别人追求某种道路的野心和动力是无法与你的一致的。而且我认为，专注于别人的计划，专注于别人对成就感的定义，专注于别人的成功，只会真正减损你对自己生活的享受，因为你总是在拿自己和别人做对照。俗话说得好，能量流向哪里，注意力就在哪里。如果你在这个十年里需要一样东西来打造你的理想生活，那就是把你的所有能量集中在能让你快乐的事情上，无论是在当下还是在未来。
I say that third factor of what conditions are necessary as the last one, because I think that this should enable those first two factors. It's also something that is most flexible, and it shouldn't be a condition or a factor that limits what you're looking for in your life. When we start making a plan for the future, especially during this decade, I think we often set out to make a bit of a checklist, one that feels very constrictive and linear. you know, do X to achieve Y, pass go, collect certain experiences, achieve certain milestones, and happiness is kind of guaranteed. And when we put ourselves into a category where we feel like we need to meet certain conditions
所以我们的第一个练习是确定你希望你的二十多岁是怎样的一个十年。请注意，这可以，而且我认为肯定会改变，你应该经常去检验这个想法。但在每一个阶段，当你发现自己可能处于十字路口或者感到非常迷茫时（我们知道这是一种超级常见的经历），你需要问自己的是：A，什么能让你快乐？B，什么能让你有成就感？因为这两者是不同的。以及C，实现这两个因素需要什么条件。
to do something, we also feel that we can't do everything and that we're closing ourselves off to other possibilities, which actually creates a lot of paralysis. because if we are feeling like we're forced to make a decision, if we're feeling like we have to give up opportunities in order to pursue something in particular, that's going to really decrease our motivation and our sense of satisfaction with that choice. And I think what's more accurate is that you can't do everything at once, but you can do everything. Ten years is a really, really long time. And I think to put that into perspective, think about everything,
我把“需要什么条件”作为最后一个因素，是因为我认为这应该服务于前两个因素。这也是最具灵活性的东西，它不应该成为限制你在生活中寻找什么的条件或因素。当我们开始为未来制定计划时，尤其是在这个十年里，我认为我们经常着手制定一份清单，一份感觉非常具有限制性和线性化的清单。
that has happened to you since you were 10 or since you were 12 or 15 or how many different chapters you've lived through since that age you were 10 years ago. How much your ideas about the future changed in that time? I think in order to confront a lot of that anxiety about wasting our formative years, we need to look at our 20s as a series of seasons. So 20 to 22 is season one. Maybe we focus on uni, we focus on figuring things out. 23 to 25, season two, we focus on giving our passions, our all, you know, really focusing on something that is perhaps not conventional or accepted, but something that makes us happy. 26 to 28, we can travel if we want. That's another option. 29 to 30 to 31. We can really focus on some level of professional or career development and viewing
你知道，做X以实现Y，通过起点，收集某些经历，达成某些里程碑，幸福似乎就有了保障。当我们把自己归入某种类别，觉得我们需要满足某些条件才能去做某事时，我们也会觉得自己无法做到面面俱到，并且我们在对自己关闭其他可能性，这实际上会造成巨大的瘫痪感。因为如果我们觉得被迫做出决定，如果我们觉得为了追求某种特定的东西就不得不放弃机会，这将会大大降低我们对该选择的动力和满足感。我认为更准确的说法是，你不可能同时做所有事情，但你可以做所有事情。十年是一段非常非常长的时间。为了把它放在一个宏观视角来看，想想看，
it as a series of chapters rather than just one clump of 10 years where you have to do everything possible, I think that makes us feel like we can fit it all in. Instead of creating a timeline or a checklist, a very constrictive way of looking at your life, I want us to utilize the ideas around visualization to create a more realistic depiction of what our future might look like, but also one that can be flexible. Instead of thinking this is what I want to achieve by 25 or 28 or 30, whatever age you have in mind, I want you to instead imagine a random day one year from now and picture the following things. Where are you living? And in detail, what does your space look like? Where did you wake up this morning? What's your morning routine? Maybe you went and saw some friends for lunch.
自从你10岁、12岁、15岁以来，或者自从你10年前那个年龄以来，在你身上发生了多少事情，你经历了多少不同的篇章。在这期间，你对未来的想法发生了多大变化。我认为，为了对抗对浪费塑造期的焦虑，我们需要将二十多岁视为一系列的“季节”。所以20到22岁是第一季。也许我们专注于大学，专注于弄清楚状况。23到25岁是第二季，我们专注于全力以赴地投入我们的激情，你知道，真正专注于一些可能并不常规或不被接受、但能让我们快乐的事情。26到28岁，如果我们想的话可以去旅行。这是另一种选择。29到30到31岁。我们可以真正专注于某个层面的职业或事业发展，并将其
Who are they? Who are these friends? What do they? What do they? do? How are you spending your afternoon? Are you working in a cafe? Are you working at, you know, the job you've always wanted or taking a train somewhere amazing? Who you were texting? Who are you talking to? Who are you fantasizing about? What are the plans that you're working towards? What are you eating for dinner? And then project that same visualization again for the version of you in five years. think about in that moment what is making you happy. What is your routine looking like? What does the world around you look like? And what small things from that do you need to change to make that feeling a reality? The thing is, I think deep down, we already know what kind of future we want, or at least we know
视为一系列的篇章，而不是把它看作是一大块必须完成所有可能之事的十年，我觉得这会让我们觉得我们可以把一切都容纳进去。我不想让大家去制定时间表或检查清单这种非常束缚生活的方式，而是希望大家利用视觉化的理念来勾勒出我们未来可能样子的更现实的描绘，同时也具备一定的灵活性。我不要你想着“这是我在25岁、28岁或30岁（无论你心里想的是哪个年龄）之前想要实现的”，我希望你去想象一年后的某个随机一天，并描绘以下情景。你住在哪里？详细说说，你的空间是什么样子的？你今天早上是在哪里醒来的？你的晨间日常是什么？也许你和一些朋友去吃午饭了。
at least one version of that. The only doubt I think we have intrinsically is our fear that we may not achieve it. But then when we picture our future and ourselves in it, when we use that very powerful tool of visualization, that's not only a really powerful motivator, but it's also incredibly affirming and it makes us look for a practical pathway to achieving a certain feeling rather than a quantifiable set of milestones. Now that we have that dream in mind, I really want to discuss how we can form our life around that dream or around the feeling that we're looking to achieve. So this is where I really want to discuss my firstly five key tips for pushing yourself forward and making the most out of your career decisions during this decade.
他们是谁？这些朋友是谁？他们在做什么？你的下午是怎么度过的？你在咖啡馆工作吗？你在做你一直梦寐以求的工作，还是坐火车去某个了不起的地方？你在给谁发信息？你在和谁聊天？你在对谁想入非非？你正在为实现什么计划而努力？你晚饭吃什么？然后再次为五年后的那个版本的自己进行同样的视觉化投射。想想在那一刻是什么让你感到快乐。你的日常是什么样的？你周围的世界是什么样的？为了让这种感觉变成现实，你需要改变其中的哪些小事情？事情是这样的，我认为在内心深处，我们已经知道自己想要什么样的未来，或者至少我们知道
I think the secret to creating your dream life in your 20s is a combination of both future planning and risk taking, striking that balance. So firstly, depending on what season you're in, whether you have a plan or not, you really need to try as many new things as you can, even when they feel scary. There's this beautiful quote that I reflect on a lot. The unlived life is not worth examining. I think too many of us believe that our 20s are for thinking about what we want to do and imagining our future, but actually not doing much doing.
其中一个版本。我认为我们内心唯一的疑虑就是害怕自己无法实现它。但随后，当我们描绘我们的未来以及身处其中的自己时，当我们使用视觉化这个强有力的工具时，这不仅是一个非常强大的推动力，而且极其具有肯定作用，它让我们去寻找实现某种特定感觉的实际途径，而不是去追求一组可量化的里程碑。现在我们心里有了那个梦想，我真的很想讨论我们如何围绕这个梦想或我们想要实现的感觉来塑造我们的生活。所以接下来，我将重点分享我关于在这十年中推动自己前进并充分利用职业决策的五个核心建议。
That's not true. I think our 20s are for collecting the experiences and the stories that will be the bedrock for our future rather than kind of falling into what we call the cycle of inaction regret. So inaction regret, we've spoken about this before, but researchers have shown that doing something, even if it's the wrong thing, taking risks, even if they don't work out, is much less likely to leave you with regret than doing nothing at all. I think additionally, our 20s are when we are most receptive to new experiences and new interests whilst our, you know, our brain are still developing. So it really is the best time to expose ourselves to novelty and newness
我认为在二十多岁时打造理想生活秘诀，在于未来规划和承担风险的结合，要找到那种平衡。首先，无论你处于哪个阶段，无论你是否有计划，你真的需要尝试尽可能多的新事物，即使它们让你感到害怕。有一句美丽的语录我经常反思：“未经审视的生活不值得过。”我认为我们当中有太多人认为，二十多岁是用来思考我们想做什么、想象未来的时候，但实际上并没有真正付诸行动。
and things that might challenge our thinking rather than feeling like we're stuck as the same version as we were when we were 18 or 19 years old. The thing is you haven't really been an adult for all too long. So it's unlikely that you really know what you like, what makes you happy, you really haven't had that exposure to what's out there. And sadly, I think you can't really figure out what is going to leave you feeling fulfilled unless you give things a really solid go. And like I said before, let life truly surprise you. I had this friend who spent like her whole life thinking that she was going to be a doctor. She had five months left of medical school and someone got her random pottery course for her birthday
事实并非如此。我认为二十多岁是用来收集那些将成为我们未来基石的经历和故事的时期，而不是陷入我们所谓的“不作为遗憾”的循环中。所以关于不作为遗憾，我们以前讨论过，但研究表明，去做某事（即使做错了），去承担风险（即使没有成功），也比什么都不做更不容易让你留下遗憾。我认为此外，二十多岁是我们的大脑仍在发育的同时，对新体验和新兴趣最容易接受的时期。所以这真的是让我们接触新鲜事物、挑战思维的最佳时机，而不是让自己感觉像个18或19岁时一成不变的版本。问题是，你当成年人的时间其实并不长。所以你不太可能真正知道自己喜欢什么、什么能让你快乐，你其实还没有接触过外面的世界。可悲的是，我认为除非你真正全力以赴地去尝试，否则你无法弄清楚是什么会让你感到满足。正如我之前所说，让生活真正给你带来惊喜。我有个朋友，她大半生都以为自己会成为一名医生。离她医学院毕业还有五个月时，有人送了她一个随意的陶艺课程作为生日礼物
and within two weeks she'd quit medical school and was focusing on being an artist full time. And I know that sounds really drastic, but this is the time. for you to do that because you can't really hurt anyone by deciding to make yourself happier in those moments and by deciding to pursue something that might be different. If you are in a moment of stagnation, you've been doing the same thing for some time. It's time to switch it up because I think you don't want to blink and realize that the things you did at 22 are the same stories you're telling at 28 because you haven't given yourself the space to be uncomfortable and make new experiences. This leads me to tip two. Take as many risks as possible, even if they're not conventional, because you
结果不到两周她就退了医学院，全职当起了艺术家。我知道这听起来很极端，但这就是你应该去做的时刻，因为在这个时刻，决定让自己更快乐、决定去追求一些可能不同的东西，并不会真正伤害到任何人。如果你正处于停滞期，做着同样的事情已经有一段时间了。是时候改变一下了，因为你肯定不想一眨眼才意识到，你22岁时做过的事，到了28岁时还在拿出来当故事讲，原因仅仅是你没有给自己留出空间去感到不舒服并经历新事物。这就引出了我的第二条建议。尽可能多地承担风险，即使它们并不常规，因为你
have no idea how they might pay off. One thing in particular, I think everyone should be doing in their 20s is to move to a new city. Pushing yourself into a new environment is such a catalyst for self-growth and self-awareness. Let this be your motivation if you have been thinking about it, learning to live on your own, support yourself and create new connections beyond what you're comfortable in. For me, that has been such a profound contributor to my identity, a huge hallmark of my 20s. And I think my sense of independence, my confidence, even, you know, my overall enjoyment in life has just blossomed, expanded, grown a hundred times. I can't even fathom how many things I would have missed out on.
根本不知道它们会带来怎样的回报。其中特别的一点是，我认为每个人在二十多岁时都应该做的事，就是搬到一个新的城市。把自己推到一个新的环境中，是自我成长和自我觉醒的强大催化剂。如果你一直在考虑这件事，那就以此为动力吧，学会独自生活，养活自己，并建立超越舒适圈的新联系。对我来说，这对我身份的塑造产生了深远的影响，是我二十多岁时的一个巨大标志。而且我认为我的独立意识、自信心，甚至我对生活总的来说的享受，都因此绽放、扩展、增长了一百倍。我甚至无法想象自己会错过多少事情
if I hadn't left home at 17 and then again moved to Sydney at 22. It really scares me to think about that. All these beautiful experiences that I was rewarded with for taking that risk, even when it felt scary, I just can't imagine how empty I would feel if I hadn't done that and how haunted I would be by the possibility. I always say this, but I think the easiest thing you can do is what is most convenient. And sadly, I think that's normally the path most people take, one of comfort and convenience where we really have, you know, we never give ourselves a reason
如果我没有在17岁时离开家，然后在22岁时再次搬到悉尼的话。想到这里我就感到害怕。所有这些由于我承担了那个风险而获得的奇妙经历，即使当时觉得很害怕，我简直无法想象如果我没有这样做，我会感到多么空虚，又会被那种可能性纠缠得多么痛苦。我总是这么说，但我认为最简单的事就是做那些最便利的事。可悲的是，我认为这通常是大多数人选择的道路，一条充满舒适和便利的道路，在这里我们真的（你知道的），我们从来不给自己任何理由
to challenge whether our lives could be better because we are too scared that we might make them worse. There's two things I want to say about that. Firstly, there is really only so much screwing up that you can do in your 20s and there are only a very select few amount of decisions that are going to ruin your life. Everything is temporary, firstly, but also everything can be reversed except for the decisions that you didn't make. I'm going to say that one more time. Everything can be reversed except for the decisions that you didn't make. And I'm not asking you to do something fraudulent or dangerous, but just to do things you are scared to do because I think living with that existential potential and question of the what if is going to be a lot more
去质疑我们的生活是否可以变得更好，因为我们太害怕把生活弄得更糟了。关于这一点，我想说两件事。首先，你在二十多岁时能把事情搞砸的程度其实是有限的，而且只有极少数的决定会真正毁掉你的生活。首先，一切都是暂时的，但同时，除了那些你没有做出的决定外，一切都可以逆转。我要再重复一遍。除了那些你没有做出的决定外，一切都可以逆转。我并不是要求你去做什么欺诈或危险的事情，而是去做那些你害怕去做的事情，因为我认为从长远来看，带着那种存在主义的潜能和“如果当初”的疑问生活，在情感上要比经历那一刻的恐惧痛苦得多。其次，在心理学中有一个关于界限风险和无界风险区别的概念，它进一步证明了你可以抓住机遇，同时依然追求那些目标并感到安全。界限风险是指那些下行风险有限，但上行收益无限的风险。所以这类风险，它们可能在前期需要你付出代价。它们可能涉及时间、金钱或资源的投入，但上限是没有限制的。潜在的好处和回报是没有上限的。比如开启一个播客、一份副业、一个YouTube频道，或者选择为自己热衷的事物重返校园。这些都是
emotionally painful in the long term than that experience of momentary fear. Secondly, there's this idea and psychology around the distinction between bounded and unbounded risk that just kind of furthers the argument that you can take chances and still pursue those same goals and still feel secure. Bounded risks are risks that have limited downside, but unbounded, unlimited upside. So these kinds of risks, they might cost you up front. They might involve an investment in time or money or resources, but there is no ceiling. There is no limit. to the potential upsides and reward. So starting a podcast, for example, a side hustle, a YouTube channel, choosing to go back to uni for something you're passionate about. Those are all examples
界限风险的例子。你投入一些时间在内容创作上，或者投入一些资金在设备或会员上，但这不会花掉你的生命、你的友谊、你的职业生涯、你的财务安全，它只会增强那些已经存在的功能。而且，你知道，如果它没有起色，如果你的播客不成功，你承受的损失是有界的。你不会损失超过你所投入的资金，你知道的，但如果它病毒式传播，或者你找到了一个高度活跃的受众，或者你发现了这种真正小众的激情和对你技能的需求，那它的发展是不可限量的。我给你举一个我最熟悉的例子，也就是关于此时此刻你正在收听的这个节目和播客。当我开始做它的时候，是的，有，你知道的，
of bounded risks. You invest sometime in content creation or study some money in equipment or a membership, but it's not going to cost you your life, your friendships, your career, your financial security, it's just going to enhance the features that are already there. And, you know, if it doesn't take off, if your podcast isn't successful, you have a bounded loss. You can't lose more than what you invested in, you know, but if it grows viral or you find a highly engaged audience, or you discover this really niche passion and a demand for your skills, there is no limit to how far that can go. I'm going to give you the example I know best, which is in terms of this show and this podcast that you're listening to right now. When I started it, yeah, there was, you know,
风险是有限的。你投入一些时间创作内容，或者花一点钱买设备或会员，但这不会搭上你的生活、友情、事业或财务安全，它只会为你现有的生活锦上添花。而且，你知道，如果它没有火起来，如果你的播客不成功，你的损失也是有限的。你不会损失超过你投资的金额，但如果它病毒式传播，或者你找到了一个高度活跃的受众，或者你发现了这种真正小众的热情以及对你技能的需求，那么它能走多远是没有任何上限的。我将举一个我最了解的例子，那就是关于这个节目和你现在正在收听的这个播客。当我开始做这个节目的时候，是的，有，你知道的，
potential to be embarrassed, but really the worst that could have happened was that no one listened. And guess what? If I hadn't started the podcast, no one would be listening anyways. But theoretically, when you choose something like a bounded risk, like starting a YouTube channel or a podcast or a TikTok, something like that, theoretically, you can reach anyone with an internet connection. there is limited cost and then also unlimited payoff. You know, this is my job now. That's so crazy to me. This is my calling.
可能会觉得尴尬，但实际上最糟糕的结果也就是没人听。你猜怎么着？如果我当初没做这个播客，反正也不会有人听。但理论上讲，当你选择像有限风险这样的人生时，比如开个YouTube频道、播客或TikTok之类的，理论上，你只要有网络就能接触到任何人。成本有限，回报却无限。你知道的，我现在这就是我的工作。这对我来说太疯狂了。这就是我的天职。
And the why is so clear to me, but if I'd been too scared or uncomfortable to take that risk, none of that would have happened. So maybe I'm a success story. Maybe I'm not. But you really have no idea what the world will reward you with when you decide to do things that most people feel too afraid to do. and, you know, it's your 20s. At the end of the day, mistakes just make for excellent stories. And some people may see a downside in that, but I think good stories just make you a more fascinating,
我非常清楚自己为什么要做这件事，但如果我当时因为害怕或感到不适而不敢去冒险，这一切都不会发生。所以也许我是个成功的故事。也许我不是。但当你决定去做大多数人感到害怕的事时，你真的无法预料世界会给予你怎样的回报。而且，你知道的，你正处于20多岁。说到底，犯错只会带来精彩的故事。有些人可能会觉得这有什么不好的，但我认为好的故事只会让你成为一个更迷人、
multidimensional human. So why not do it? And one of the best risks I think you can take. And also, my third tip is to quit the job you hate. I've spoken about this before. And to be honest, people weren't too big of a fan of it, but I really want to lay out my evidence and reasoning for this if anyone out there needs convincing. This is not the decade for you to stay anywhere, do anything you don't love out of an obligation. You have years of that, years to do that, years to put yourself through the responsibility of needing to keep a job. I don't think now is that time. When we're talking about creating our dream life, if you are someone who is working full time, one third of that life you are creating will be at work.
更有立体感的人。所以为什么不去做呢？我认为你可以去承担的最佳风险之一，我的第三个建议就是：辞掉你讨厌的工作。我以前谈过这个话题。说实话，大家对这个观点的反感并不大，但如果有人需要被说服，我真的很想把我的证据和理由摆出来。在这个十年里，你不应该仅仅出于义务，而把时间浪费在任何你不喜欢的地方、做任何你不喜欢的事。你以后有的是时间去经历这些，有的是时间去做那些事，有的是时间去承担必须保住一份工作的责任。我认为现在不是那个时候。当我们谈论创造梦想中的生活时，如果你是一名全职工作者，你创造的这种生活中有三分之一是在工作中度过的。
When we look at our life in its totality, that is 30% of our time, 90,000 hours. 90,000 hours of your life. I can't even begin to contemplate how large that number is. Imagine being in the biggest stadium you've ever been in, and imagine talking to every single person in that stadium for an hour, row by row, section by section, seat by seat. That would take an incredibly long time. and that is the time that you're investing into a job that you might not love,
当我们全面审视自己的人生时，那占据了我们30%的时间，足足9万个小时。你生命中的9万个小时。我甚至无法开始想象这个数字有多大。想象一下，你身处你见过最大的体育场里，想象一下跟那个体育场里的每一个人交谈一个小时，一排接一排，一片接一片，座位接座位。那将花费极其漫长的时间。而这些时间，全都被你投入到了一份你可能并不热爱的工作中，
that you might not like, that leaves you overworked, miserable, bored, unfulfilled, and so can you really give yourself a reason other than money and stability why you should stay? And when you create a hierarchy of what's important to you, does money really sit above your well-being or your happiness and your joy in life? I'm guessing probably not, and it goes back to that first item, You need to try as many new things as you can because there could be a job out there for you that you absolutely adore that you, you know, leaves you feeling so happy and fulfilled and meaningful.
一份你可能并不喜欢的工作，它让你过度劳累、痛苦不堪、感到无聊、毫无成就感。所以除了金钱和稳定之外，你真的能给自己一个留下来理由吗？当你把对你重要的事情按层级排列时，金钱真的能凌驾于你的幸福感、快乐或生活中的喜悦之上吗？我猜大概率不会。这就回到了第一点，你需要尽可能多地尝试新鲜事物，因为外面可能有一份你极其热爱的工作，它能让你感到无比快乐、充实和有意义。
So why don't you deserve to be there? This is really your only life and work is a part of that. It's a part of that reality. So in 10, 20 years, are you going to be proud of yourself if you stayed somewhere you weren't happy just because it was easier than the effort, it would take to do something that you loved more. Quit the job. Trust me, I did it. You have time to be a corporate drone. You have time to sell your soul to a boss. But I don't think that your 20s are that time. That advice might sound quite militant and intense, maybe a bit Marxist, which I get. I understand.
那你为什么不值得拥有那样的生活呢？这真的才是你仅此一次的人生，而工作只是其中的一部分。它是现实的一部分。所以在10年或20年后，如果你仅仅因为“这样做比付出努力去追求所爱更轻松”，就留在一个让你并不快乐的地方，你会为自己感到骄傲吗？辞掉那份工作吧。相信我，我这么做过。你以后有的是时间当公司的螺丝钉。你以后有的是时间把灵魂出卖给老板。但我不认为20多岁是该做这种事的时候。这个建议听起来可能有些激进和强烈，也许有点像马克思主义，我懂，我理解。
But I also want to say, if you love your job, that is absolutely something that you should hold onto. You are very lucky. And I think that that is a real blessing. Congratulations. but this advice is for if you have any doubts that your current career is not bringing you fulfillment. I do think that that lack of fulfillment, that dissatisfaction, is only solidified over time. So to give you that edge, this really relates to my next tip and to be able to transfer to new jobs, new beginnings, but also to give you the freedom to transition perhaps between work and time exploring and trying other things. My fourth tip is to develop a specific skill, something that is very unique as almost an insurance for your future. So things like audio editing,
但我也想说，如果你热爱你的工作，那绝对是你应该坚持的东西。你非常幸运。我认为这真的是一种福气。恭喜你。但这个建议是针对那些对目前的职业无法带来成就感而心存疑虑的人。我的确认为，这种缺乏成就感和不满意的情绪，只会随着时间的推移而不断加固。为了让你更具优势，这其实与我的下一个建议息息相关——不仅要能适应新工作、新起点，还要让自己拥有在工作、探索时间和尝试其他事物之间自由转换的能力。我的第四个建议是：培养一项特定的技能，一项非常独特的技能，作为你未来的某种保险。比如音频剪辑，
things like being a nurse, things like copywriting, some kind of coding, a unique skill, a unique thing that you can put on your resume that is evergreen, that is always going to have some kind of commodification. So why is this valuable and why is it on this list? I think this is valuable because it gives you the security to be able to make decisions from a place of longing and from your heart rather than practicality, knowing that you have something to fall back onto, whilst also expanding the avenues and dimensions of your life beyond your career. Whatever you choose to do, that is totally up to you. But I also think that I cannot see here and give advice about creating a beautiful future if we're not also thinking about what that foundation might look like.
比如当护士，比如文案写作，某种编程，一项独特的技能，一项可以写进你简历里且永不过时、永远都会有某种市场价值的独特本事。那么，为什么这很有价值？为什么它会出现在这个清单上？我认为这很有价值，是因为它赋予了你一种安全感，让你能够从渴望和内心出发来做出决定，而不是完全出于实用性，因为你知道自己还有退路，同时它也能拓宽你职业之外的人生广度和维度。无论你选择做什么，这完全取决于你。但我也认为，如果我们不考虑基础会是什么样，就无法坐在这里为创造美好的未来提供建议。
and some of the practicalities and, you know, contextual factors around needing money to live and needing money to explore and needing money to take time off work. So I think that made five, but I'm going to give one extra, and that is to start writing down your goals and setting up five achievable goals per year. So one professional goal, one personal goal, one financial goal, one health goal, And finally, what I call a soulful goal. So that is a goal that feeds you mentally, psychologically, emotionally, that may not look like something we would set as a goal from the outside. It might not look important to others, but it's important for ourselves and for keeping in
以及其中的一些现实情况，你知道的，包括需要钱来生活、需要钱去探索、需要钱来请假休息等各种现实因素。所以我想前面已经说到第五点了，但我还要再补充额外的一点，那就是：开始写下你的目标，每年设定五个可实现的宏伟目标。即一个职业目标、一个个人目标、一个财务目标、一个健康目标，最后是我所说的“心灵目标”。也就是一个能在精神、心理和情感上滋养你的目标，从外表来看，它可能不像我们通常设定的那种目标。在别人眼里它可能显得无足轻重，但对我们自己以及保持内心的
touch with our authenticity and our sense of wonder. Ad adulthood, if we take it too seriously, sometimes can suck a lot of the fun out of our 20s. You know, remember what it was like when you played like a bunch of instruments and you played sport with your friends and you were like building a sticker collection or you were like making little songs on your keyboard, that is still important in our 20s. So I think focusing on something that elevates the small pleasures and keeps you centered on enjoying life is really important. You know, maybe pursuing a sport or a yoga course or making time to make art, asking
真实感和惊奇感至关重要。如果我们把成年生活看得太严肃，有时会夺走20多岁时的大部分乐趣。你知道的，还记得你以前玩过各种乐器、和朋友一起做运动、收集贴纸，或者在电子琴上弹奏小曲的那种感觉吗？在20多岁时，这些依然很重要。所以我认为，专注于那些能提升小确幸、让你专注于享受生活的事物真的很重要。比如，去追求一项运动、上一门瑜伽课，或者留出时间去创作艺术，问问
yourself, like, I want to make a couple of art pieces a year and I'm not going to give them to anyone, I'm just going to keep them to myself. I want to make sure that I plan at least one beach trip or I do a girl's trip or a trip on my own, something that is going to feed your soul that you prioritize in your life. That is an important part of the goals that you're setting for the future. I think those five goals, those five categories, give your life a sense of structure so that you're not kind of sucked into a Peter Pan complex, wanting to be aimless and young forever. But it also keeps the balance, balance being the key word of this episode between focus and freedom. Importantly, we also have to recognize that these goals, they may and most likely will change.
自己，比如：我每年都想创作几件艺术品，而且我不会送给任何人，我只想留给自己。我要确保自己至少计划一次海滩之旅，或者来一次闺蜜游、独自旅行——做一些能滋养你的灵魂、并在你的生活中将其置于优先地位的事情。这是你为未来设定的目标中至关重要的一部分。我认为这五个目标、这五个类别为你的生活赋予了一种结构感，这样你就不会陷入“彼得·潘综合征”，不会总想漫无目的地永远年轻。但它也保持了平衡——“平衡”正是本集的核心关键词——在专注与自由之间找到平衡。重要的是，我们还得认识到，这些目标可能会、而且极有可能会发生改变。
And also, you don't need to achieve them in the next two days or the next two weeks. One of the biggest mistakes I think we make in our 20s is feeling like everything is on an accelerated timeline, such that the time between an idea and it's really, needs to be as quick as possible. Maturing is really coming to terms with the fact that good things take time and adjustment and plans made in silence with consistency and slow, steady action are a lot more structurally sound than kind of these fleeting desires that we throw everything into. And I'm not saying don't do those things, but I think have some idea in mind of where you might want to be in 10 years.
而且，你也不需要在接下来的两天或两周内就全部实现它们。我认为我们在20多岁时犯下的最大错误之一，就是觉得一切都在加速的轨道上，好比从产生一个想法到它真正落地之间的时间，必须要尽可能地短。走向成熟，其实就是去接受这样一件事实：美好的事物需要时间去沉淀和调整，在沉默中保持一致性并采取缓慢、稳健行动所制定的计划，要比那些让我们倾注一切的转瞬即逝的欲望，在结构上要稳固得多。我并不是说不要去做那些事，但我觉得心里还是得有个底，知道自己10年后想去哪里。
I really get that tendency to rush and feel pressure to be successful and exceptional at a young age, especially with so much societal pressure and the idealization of the wonderkin, the young success story. But really slow down and take this moment for what it is. You're never going to get this time back. That's something I hear time and time again from mentors or people who are older than me. Plans will take time. You don't need to rush and get them done right now. You are completely okay to have your small micro goals that give you a sense of motivation and give you a sense of that visualization tactic we were talking about before.
我真的很理解那种急于求成、渴望在年轻时就获得成功和出类拔萃的压力，特别是面对这么大的社会压力以及对“神童”和年轻成功故事的理想化时。但实际上，慢下来，去好好体验当下这一刻吧。你永远无法倒回这段时光。这是我一次又一次从导师或年长我的人那里听到的话。计划需要时间。你不需要急着现在就把它们全部搞定。拥有一些能给你带来动力、以及我们之前讨论过的可视化技巧的微小目标，是完全没问题的。
You know, if your goal is to do something huge, how can you prepare for that over time in a way that is sustainable? Focusing on the little steps you take and tying them back to the big, but also giving yourself freedom around that to go on trips, to do things that really spark joy and feel excited. and feel like the experiences we should be having in our 20s. I think we've had enough career advice and conversations on careers so far in this episode. So what I want to move on to talking about next is finances and money. Not something we talk about on the show a lot, but really important nonetheless, something extremely valuable to discuss when we are contemplating this idea of our dream life and how to set ourselves up for success in our 20s.
你知道的，如果你的目标是做一件大事，你该如何在可持续的前提下随着时间慢慢为此做准备呢？专注于你所迈出的每一步，并将它们与宏伟的目标联系起来，同时也要给自己留出自由的空间去旅行、去做那些能真正点燃快乐、让你感到兴奋的事情。并且去感受那些我们在20多岁时本该经历的体验。我想在本集的节目中，我们已经聊了足够多的职业建议和职场话题。所以接下来我想探讨的是财务和金钱。虽然我们在节目中不常谈论这个，但它同样极其重要，当我们思考梦想中的生活以及如何在20多岁时为成功打下基础时，这是一个极具价值的讨论话题。
So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
所有这些内容以及更多精彩，将在短暂的广告之后为您呈现。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可供选择时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在光怪陆离的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看穿充斥在健康产业中那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经笃信种子油天然具有炎症性。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。节目名称是“TWO Percent”，可在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有毛线关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过那段时期的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day But just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack So I'm starting to see that there's a through line
包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·hill的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅是因为快克。我随时准备在白天聊聊快克。但为了让大家知道，马克，这已经是我们第二期讨论快克了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。
We also have AIDS on the table right now So Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years For black people in American history
我们现在还把艾滋病摆上台面了，所以。谢谢你接上那句话。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的，对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
收听《Look Back at it》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人、也是你们最喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，与众多不可思议的嘉宾展开深度对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
我说的就是崔普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们去追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在盯着计分板。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要，还是说你做个好人只是因为你心存恐惧？因为老兄，这是两种完全不同的动机。绝对是的。这也是两种不同层级的信任。我希望你能真正发自内心地去做一个好人。加入我和吉尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就疗愈、
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much.
成长、父职、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开您免费的iHeart Radio应用程序，搜索“Learning a Hardway”并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他供词中惊人的矛盾之处。这就引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你把这份特定的测试报告篡改了整整两次，在这么多地方。
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破获了这个案子。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一种令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我整个人惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Money in our 20s is something that we do not discuss a lot. I think because our positions on kind of the wealth scale between our friends, our colleagues, and then people like our parents, is so nuanced and diverse that it feels awkward to speak on. You know, we have friends who are still at uni. Some of them are working. we don't really want to put it out there that we might have less money than there might have more.
这一切都还没结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我们在20多岁时很少讨论金钱。我想这是因为我们在朋友、同事以及像父母这样的人之间的财富阶层定位是如此微妙且多元，以至于说出来会让人觉得尴尬。你知道的，我们有些朋友还在上大学。他们当中有些人已经在工作了。我们其实并不想显摆自己可能比别人钱少，或者可能比别人钱多。
There's also this level of discomfort and shame and taboo around money, which I actually think is not doing us any favors. It's not empowering us to make informed decisions. Like, how do I spend my money in my 20s? Is everyone saving money? Does everyone have money for a house? Or is everyone as frivolous as me? Is everyone prioritizing experiences?
围绕金钱，也存在着某种程度的不适、羞耻和禁忌，而我其实认为这并没有给我们带来任何好处。它并没有赋予我们做出明智决策的力量。比如，我在20多岁时该怎么花钱？大家都在存钱吗？每个人都有买房的钱吗？还是说所有人都跟我一样大手大脚？每个人都把体验放在首位吗？
it's really hard to know because I think not only do people not talk about it in our personal lives, but there are very, very few discussions about it in things like our education system or even online in the media. So let's crack that open today. Let's really examine maybe how you should be spending your money in your 20s. I'm going to make a really big caveat here. You should be spending your money how you want to spend it. I think financial responsibility and literacy is something.
这真的很难知道，因为我认为不仅在我们的个人生活中人们不愿谈论它，而且在诸如我们的教育系统甚至网络媒体中，关于它的讨论也少之又少。所以今天让我们打破这个禁忌。让我们好好审视一下，你在20多岁时究竟该如何花钱。这里我要做一个非常重要的前提声明。你应该按照你想花的方式去花你的钱。我认为财务责任和理财素养是一回事，
that we all claim in our own time. And I also think this is just my opinion and my advice for how I choose to spend my money and how I'm trying to set myself up for a success. I also think this is a psychology podcast and we cannot discuss our opinions and perspectives and feelings towards money without thinking about where that came from. I think whilst we should save when and where we can, when possible, we also need to reframe money as a resource and a resource and a tool rather than as a source of joy. But some of us have had different childhood perspectives on that and different influential experiences around money that have influenced how we treat it in our 20s. For example, you know, if you never really had much, money is really synonymous to you with
我们都会在各自的时间里去掌握它。而且我也认为这只是我的个人观点，以及我选择如何花钱、我如何努力为自己争取成功的建议。我还认为这是一个心理学播客，如果不去思考这些想法、观点和对金钱的情感是从何而来的，我们就无法探讨我们对金钱的看法、观点和感受。我认为虽然我们应该在可能的时候量入为出、能省则省，但我们也需要重新将金钱框定为一种资源和工具，而不是快乐的源泉。但我们有些人对此有着不同的童年视角，以及围绕金钱的不同成长经历，这些都影响了我们在20多岁时对待金钱的方式。例如，你知道的，如果你过去从来没拥有过什么，金钱对你来说就真正等同于
security. So you might hang on to it and feel a lot worse or a lot more negative around spending money on things that might bring you joy. Or you might go the opposite way if you've never had much money. You might now not really know how to manage this as a resource and use it to pursue luxury and to give you the things that you never had. I also think there are a lot of experiences, particularly when we're younger and how money is treated by our parents and by people around us that can cause us to conflate income with self-worth and with just worth in general. So I think the first thing we really need to do is de-centre money from our life. When we speak about some of those earlier points around taking risk and quitting your job, money is going to be a powerful factor,
安全感。所以你可能会紧紧攥着钱，而在把钱花在那些能给你带来快乐的事物上时，会感到更多的糟糕感或负面情绪。或者，如果你以前没怎么见过钱，你可能会走向另一个极端。你现在可能并不真正知道如何将这笔钱作为一种资源来管理，并用它去追求奢侈生活、去弥补你从未得到过的一切。我还认为有很多经历，特别是当我们还年轻的时候，父母和身边人对待金钱的方式，会导致我们把收入与自我价值以及整体价值混为一谈。所以我认为我们首先要做的是，将金钱从我们生活的中心剥离出来。当我们谈到之前提到的那些关于承担风险和辞职的观点时，金钱将是一个强大的因素，
but it's also a resource. So I think my biggest tip here is to, in your 20s, spend money on experiences rather than things. You have time to save. You have time to buy a house. You have time to make those financial investments that you want to make. And I think a lot of the media and especially around TikTok and even Reddit and things like that, a lot of what we consume from those platforms is really focused on building wealth and really focused on what investments you should be making. And I think that if it is that easy as a lot of these people claim for it to be, if you can start small, you can start small a little bit later. And I really think that you can save in small ways that don't require you to make.
但它同时也是一种资源。所以我觉得我最大的建议是，在20多岁时，要把钱花在体验上，而不是物质上。你还有时间存钱。你还有时间买房。你还有时间去进行你想要进行的那些金融投资。而且我认为很多媒体，特别是TikTok甚至Reddit之类的平台上，我们从这些平台消费的很多内容都高度聚焦于财富积累，高度聚焦于你应该进行哪些投资。但我认为，如果真的像这些人宣称的那样简单——如果你可以从小钱开始，那你稍微晚一点再开始小额投资也完全来得及。我真的觉得你可以通过一些小方法来存钱，而无需在人生本该拥有更多自由去享受周围事物的阶段，去做出剧烈的生活调整。所以把钱花在体验上，而不是物质上，我认为是实现这一点的好方法。我经常思考的一个重大问题是，物质商品并不是你在50年后会铭记的东西。你知道的，新款阿迪达斯鞋、潮流服装、昂贵的包包。是的，它现在可能会让你非常快乐，这很美好，而且当你有能力时你应该犒赏自己，但我认为它不值得你用可能因此错过的回忆或体验去交换。所以在两者之间做出选择时——在购买一件精美的物品与做一件能让你以不同视角看世界、或与朋友开怀大笑、
drastic life adjustments in a period of your life where you should have a little bit more freedom to enjoy the things around you. So spending money on experiences rather than things I think is a good way to accomplish this. One big thing I think about a lot is that material items are not the things that you are going to remember in 50 years. You know, the new Adidas shoes, trending clothing items, fancy bags. Yeah, it might make you really happy right now and that's a beautiful thing and you should be able to treat yourself when you can, but I don't think it's worth more than the memories or experiences that you might be potentially giving up. So if there's a choice between that, between a nice item, and doing something that is going to let you see the world differently, or laugh with your
或者仅仅是活在当下、对你的灵魂和经历有益的事情之间，我真的认为这才是我们应该优先考虑的。你知道的，我觉得你在20多岁时并不需要那些潮流或大牌单品来带给你快乐。我认为那些东西只是让生活更丰富、更充实的点缀或美好的加成。我以前总是用这样的借口来安慰自己：如果我买了这件东西，有一天我可以留给我的孩子们。但实际上那只会制造杂乱。你知道的，它让我开心了几天。它给了我短暂的多巴胺刺激。然后买后的负罪感就会袭来。突然间，我真的很希望自己当时有更多的钱去用来做那些我知道能陪伴我一生、
friends, or just be present, something that is good for your soul and experience, I really think that that is what we should prioritize. You know, I think you don't need trendy or does diner items to bring you joy in your 20s. I think those things are just nice benefits or nice additions to a more rich and fulfilling life. And I used to really use the justification that, you know, if I bought this thing, I would give it to my kids one day. And really that just caused clutter. You know, it made me happy for a couple of days. It gave me that short dopamine hit. And then the buyer's remorse would set in. And suddenly I really wished that I had more money to do things that I knew would last me a lifetime. like take trips with my friends, do the spontaneous dinners, go and have experiences.
比如和朋友去旅行、进行一场说走就走的晚餐、去体验生活的种种。我还认为，并不是所有的钱都必须花掉。我父母总是说的一句话是：你应该为娱乐留出专款，但永远不要花掉收入的80%以上。而且你必须始终保留一定水平的存款。所以我觉得当我们谈论储蓄、投资或把钱存起来时，会感到不知所措，因为这感觉像是要以牺牲我们的生活方式为代价。但如果你每周只存25美元到一个高息储蓄账户里，作为最低底线，这真的会开始滚雪球般增长，并变得非常、非常有成效，
I also think that not all money needs to be spent. Something that my parents always said was that you should have dedicated money for fun, but you should never spend more than 80% of your earnings. And you should always have some level of savings. So I think we get really overwhelmed when we talk about savings or investing or putting money aside because it feels like it's going to really cost us our lifestyle. But if you just put $25 a week into a high-interest savings account, bare minimum, that really begins to grow and it begins to become really, really fruitful
同时又不会让人觉得它在阻碍那些资产以及作为资源的金钱，而这些正是能够为你提供你真正渴望拥有的那些体验的支撑。其次，我们要回到社会比较这个概念上来，因为我认为这是我们在20多岁时对待金钱方式的一个巨大心理因素。在这十年里，不要为了给别人留下深刻印象而买房、花大钱租昂贵的公寓，也不要仅仅因为别人在那么做而盲目花钱。我觉得我们真的把金钱与关于我们自身的许多个人事物混为一谈了。我认为我们的社会、文化以及对财富的盲目崇拜，
without feeling like it's impeding on some of those assets and money as a resource, that can provide you with the experiences that you really want to be having. Secondly, we're going to return to this idea of social comparison because I think it's a really big psychological factor in how we approach money in our 20s. Do not buy property or spend money on rent for a fancy apartment or use money to impress people during this decade or do not spend money on things just because other people are doing it. I think that we really conflate money with a lot of personal things about ourselves. I think that our society and our culture and our really idolization of wealth
让这种现象变得根深蒂固，以至于很难摆脱。但是看着别人的消费方式并觉得自己也必须那样做，是让自己陷入一种消费模式的捷径，而这种模式或许根本不适合你的生活方式以及你对未来的宏观构想。把金钱当作一种攀比工具是非常危险的，因为我们开始把它看作关于我们自身最重要的事情，并且我们开始认为，如果我们过上某种特定的生活方式，别人就会对我们刮目相看。如果我们能宣称自己在做诸如买房或者住在超级昂贵的街区之类的事，某种程度上这会让我们更快乐。我认为我们去追求这些事情、这些奢侈品和大额投资的时代，
has made that so it's really hard to escape. But looking at how someone else is spending and feeling like you need to do that is a very easy way to find yourself trapped in a way of spending that perhaps doesn't actually suit your lifestyle and that broader visualization of where you want to be. Using money as a tool for comparison is such a danger because we start to see it as the most important thing about ourselves and we start to think that if we live, a certain lifestyle, people will think a certain way about us. If we can say that we're doing things like buying a house or staying in a really expensive neighborhood that somehow that's going to make us happier, I think our time for those things and our time for those luxuries and big investments
以后自然会到来。尤其是刚进入20多岁时，或许并不是做这些事的时候。成年的一部分就是为金钱操心。财务压力是导致焦虑和抑郁等问题最大的外生因素（即外部因素），特别是对于25岁或30岁以上的人群而言。当我们考虑到其他一些语境因素，比如潜在的经济衰退即将来临，或者一种真实的财务不确定感时，这会进一步加剧我们与金钱的关系，把它视作一种有限的资源。我认为这所导致的溢出效应或后果之一，就是对我们的财务状况采取一种自愿的盲目或无知。金钱会带来大量的压力和恐惧，
will come. Our early 20s in particular are perhaps not the time to be doing that. Part of being an adult is worrying about money. Financial stress is one of the biggest exogenous, meaning outside external factors, contributing to things like anxiety and depression, particularly amongst people over the age of 25 or 30. And when we think about some of the other contextual factors like potentially, you know, an oncoming recession or a real sense of financial uncertainty, that can further exacerbate our relationship to money as something that is finite. I think that what that causes the bleed on effects or consequences of that is partaking in a voluntary blindness or ignorance around our finances. Money can create a lot of stress and fear,
我认为这会导致我们不去审视自己是如何花钱的、为什么要花钱、在什么时候花钱，以及是为了应对什么而花钱。我认为无知确实是福，但无知也是一种限制。你想做自己想做的事，而这需要一些提前思考，同时也需要一些知识储备。我曾经过着这样一段时期：我甚至连自己的银行账户余额都不敢看。然后，当我终于坐下来思考——“好吧，我到底把大部分钱都花在什么地方了？”我发现那些东西实际上并没有给我带来多少快乐。它们带给我的只是便利。大量的叫外卖、大量的打车软件消费。是的，那种生活方式有它存在的时间和地点。但决定去了解我和金钱的关系、
and I think what that can cause us to do is to not examine how we're spending, why we're spending, when we're spending, and in response to what. And I think ignorance is definitely bliss, but ignorance is also limiting. You want to be able to do the things you want to do, and that requires some pre-thought, but also some knowledge. I really went through a time where I would not even look at my bank balance. And then when I finally sat down and was like, okay, what am I spending most of my money on here? It was things that actually didn't bring me that much joy. They just brought me convenience. A lot of takeaway, a lot of Uber rates. And yeah, there's a time and a place for that. But deciding to be knowledgeable about my
弄清楚我在哪里花钱以及在哪里可以省钱，真的非常有价值。它为我提供了一张安全网，让我能够去做自己热爱的事情，同时又不会牺牲我喜欢的生活方式——那种可以和朋友吃晚餐、去看电影的生活，而且又不会过于奢侈，也不会彻底吞噬我为那个星期或那个月存下的所有钱。你知道的，金钱是一种资源。它不是你的全部生活。而且我也不认为金钱是我们在20多岁时去追求某项职业或做出某个决定的理由，除非那是你心甘情愿做出的决定。你知道的，这就是选择去承受属于你的“困难”——比如身无分文，
relationship with money and where I was spending and where I could save was really, really valuable for giving me that bit of a safety net to be able to do the things I loved whilst also not sacrificing a lifestyle that I liked, one in which I could go and have dinners with friends, I could go and see movies, but it also wasn't going to be exorbitant and it wasn't going to completely consume all the money that I had put aside for that week or for that month. You know, money is a resource. It is not your entire life. And I also don't think that money. is a reason to pursue a certain career or to make a decision in our 20s, unless that is a decision that you are willing to make. You know, it's about choosing your hard, you know, being broke and being,
在金钱上苦苦挣扎，或许因为你优先考虑旅行、进修或追随内心而无法做某些事情。这很难。但为了能在一二十二三岁时买起第一套房子，而在自己可能并不热爱的工作上日复一日地做牛马，这也同样很难。关键在于选择你所承受的难。在这些选择以及所有其他我们可以做出的丰富选择中，到底哪一个才真正最符合我一开始让你去勾勒的那个愿景——那个关于你一年或五年后幸福模样的大胆愿景？好好想想，金钱在那幅画卷中处于什么位置？金钱是一个重要的因素吗？好了。所以我想第一部分我们就先聊到这里，
you know, really struggling with money and maybe not being able to do certain things because you're prioritizing travel or further education or following your passion. That is hard. But it's also hard slaving away at a job you might not love to be able to afford your first house at 22, 23. It's about choosing your heart. What of these choices and of the, all those other abundant choices that we could make is actually most aligned with that vision that I, that I really wanted you to set out the start, that vision of what happiness looks like for you in a year or five years. Really think about where does money sit in that picture. Is money an important factor? All right. So I think we're done with part one for now.
涵盖了我们对职业焦虑、职业风险、职业确定性的基础探讨，以及我们在这一十年中可能会遇到的部分财务责任和财务动力。我觉得这非常有价值，甚至非常重要，它重申了我对待20多岁人生的态度。我觉得自己目前正处于一种有点卡住的状态，对于未来会发生什么、我想创造什么样的生活、我是否在为那个未来做正确的事情，感到有些迷茫和不知所措。但我觉得拥有那种信念——是的，我应该去冒险；是的，我应该追随内心的激情；不，这并不意味着我的人生走到了终点；不，我不会仅仅因为在23、24岁时做了一个选择就被锁死在某种未来里——这是非常重要的一点，我认为
covering our bases around career anxiety, career risk, career certainty, and then also some of the financial responsibilities and financial motivators that we might encounter in this decade. I found this really valuable, really important actually to reaffirm how I was approaching my 20s. I think I've been feeling a little bit stuck at the moment and a little bit all over the place as to what the future holds and what kind of life I want to create and whether I'm doing the right things for that future. But I think having that sense of, yes, I should be taking a risk. Yes, I should be following something like my passion. No, that is not the end of the line for me. No, I'm not locked into a future just because I made a choice at 23, 24. That's a really important thing that I think
这一集让我能够在内心深处强化了这种认知。所以我真心希望你们会喜欢它，并回来收听第二部分。在第二部分中，我们将探讨如何创造你的梦想生活，特别是围绕人际关系、爱情、友情，当然还有个人成长。我认为尤其是爱情这个因素，是我们在20多岁时有最多疑问的一个方面，我不会假装自己拥有所有的答案，但我所研究的一些调研和研究成果让我大开眼界，促使我去反思：我是不是在以一种健康、可持续的方式来对待这种极为基础的情感体验和连接，从而与我想过的生活保持一致？所以我们将在第二部分中再次回到这个话题。一如既往，如果你
this episode allowed me to reinforce within myself. So I really hope that you enjoyed it and that you come back for part two where we're going to be talking about how to create your dream life, particularly around relationships, love, friendships, and then of course personal growth. I think that the love factor in particular is one that we have so many questions about in our 20s and I'm not going to pretend I have all of the answers, but some of the research and studies that I looked into was really eye-opening for me to be like, am I approaching this very foundational emotional experience and connection in a healthy and sustainable way that aligns with living the life I want to live. So we are going to return to that in part two. As always, if you
喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评，如果你觉得有必要的话，也可以把它分享给朋友。如果你有节目建议，请关注我们的账号 @That Psychology Podcast。我喜欢听你们的反馈。我喜欢听你们的生活正在发生什么，以及你想让我探讨什么样的体验。所以我非常感激你们给予我的所有爱意、支持和反馈，我将带着关于“如何在20多岁创造梦想生活”的第二部分回归。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听的是《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人吉尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行那些
enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now, share it with a friend if you feel cool to do so. And if you have an episode suggestion, follow us at That Psychology Podcast. I love hearing from you. I love hearing what's going on with your, with your lives, what kind of experiences you want me to talk about. So I appreciate all the love, support and feedback that you give me over there. And I will be back with part two of creating your dream life in your 20s. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations
在其他任何地方都真的不安全、无法开诚布公地进行的对话，但你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你可别想招惹我。仅仅因为你具备这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去这样做，收听在iHeart Radio应用程序上的《Learn the Hardway》，
that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app,
Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控产下双胞胎，但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你把这份特定的测试报告篡改了两次，欧文斯女士，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破获了这个案子。寻找令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor Star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我整个人惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可供选择时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在光怪陆离的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
收听《2%》。节目名称是“TWO Percent”，可在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
他绝不能就这样逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts、任何你获取播客的地方收听。这是一档iHeart播客。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast.
真人真事保证。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
百分之百真人。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。